this ear biscuit is brought to you by
Squarespace the all-in-one platform that
makes it fast and easy to create your
own professional website or online
portfolio and you know you want a
professional website don't you I want a
portfolio of my sculptures that have
been doing that you're sad if you
haven't made yeah or in my mind oh I
want a website for my mind sculptures
for a free trial and 10% off your first
purchase go to squarespace.com and use
offer code R&L are a and DL okay now you
know those websites that you go to on
your phone and then you're like oh
there's not a mobile version of the site
and you know kind of move it around and
trying to let click a link where I get
the scroll thumb yeah well with
Squarespace when you make your space it
doesn't work anymore
I'm not to the put them with the website
yeah it's not that serious
but I guess it could cause carpal tunnel
but when you create a website on
Squarespace it automatically creates the
mobile version of it so if you got a
website that you create without you
don't have to think about it you just
create what you think looks good and
then it automatically creates this
mobile experience that matches the theme
of your website matches it you know what
I'm saying I would argue that the mobile
website is more important than than the
website website well it definitely is
becoming more important so it's not
something you don't want to have
certainly not I'm definitely gonna have
one when I do my mine sculptures my mind
sculptures portfolio you'll be able to
look at those on a phone you better look
at those on it okay laptop I get it okay
okay so you can start a trial for free
even without entering your credit card
and start building your website today
but then when you decide that you do
want to sign up for Squarespace make
sure you use our offer code our ndele to
get 10% off your first purchase and to
show your support for ear biscuits yes
thanks to Squarespace for their support
of ear biscuits and it's time to bake
another one just for you
[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm Linc
thank you for listening to this very
special ear biscuit especially for your
ears your ears your ears I'm talking to
you his ears hmm that's right now
there's an interesting perspective that
you're bringing to the table today this
week at the round table of dimmed
lighting whoo interesting from the
internet are we talking to nobody each
other's man each other's that's right
okay so a month ago we did the just
rhett and Link asking each other
questions ear biscuit and we got a lot
of positive feedback on that so we have
indeed decided to continue it right now
yeah the second installment yeah I gotta
say it was fun to talk to you and ask
you questions in a way that I typically
would not there's something about you
know I don't sit all the time you know
ask you questions like dude where the
keys or it's usually a question that I
ask is that your shirt put the keys what
uh what are we doing today
why are we wearing the same shirt should
you go back in and change yeah is that
did you fart I asked you that quite a
bit too and you asked me that these are
the kinds of questions that we ask each
other has everything no I mean we have
we have conversations as friends
sometimes but it's it it they have to
kind of slide in there because there's
so much that we're trying to accomplish
something like a professional standpoint
and I'm not just saying that we don't
talk as friends I'm just saying that
there's something about the format of
being like okay I've got some questions
prepared for you you've got some
questions prepared for me that lends
itself to a different level of
authenticity or something I don't know
what it is I'm just saying that well I
don't think I don't sit around a thing
you know what I'm gonna try to remember
if there's anything that I don't know
about link or I'm gonna get you know we
don't go back and talk about those
things other than just to reminisce but
I don't know what was actually going on
in your mind at that point we don't take
time out to reminisce 60 minute in 60
minutes Shawn there you go that's what
I'm looking for in order to gain
new insight into our brain while wearing
headphones and talking into microphones
but that's what we're doing in a room
alone okay so I think we put a pin in
one topic which I started to ask and
then I said we need to wait because this
is gonna open a whole can of
conversation up on some people right and
that is I guess what can be my first
question which is Rhett why were you so
obsessed with girls growing up now do
you want you want to go do you have
anything else by way of intro that you
want to get into before you start
answering my questions
well we diving into the deep way we can
dive right into it I could premise it
with saying that if you didn't listen to
last month's episode it was us asking
questions about our childhood and then
that led into this could this question
that link casts and we were like huh you
know what this actually could be a whole
whole episode is just talking about
girls growing up right our experience
with the the greater sex is that is that
how we should say it yeah sure and you
do shouldn't say the fairer sex because
that fairer citizen really fly anymore
because some of them have pants yes I
mean if anybody use very straight answer
right now or just beachcombing
I would just say in general girls like
women's come women or Tanner than men
usually I mean the average woman that
would say can't be true that's my new
first question why would you think that
on average women are Tanner than me okay
don't answer that why was I obsessed
with girls well first of all let me you
gonna own that oh well
heck yeah I'm gonna own it I'm gonna
tell you right now that from a very
early age I would I would say definitely
first grade so basically at the time
that I met you I say a large percentage
the majority of my thoughts were
directed at girls and not just girls in
general but I had a tendency to fixate
on one girl at a time well it could be
worth maybe two or three at a time but
it was just like fixate from a distance
yeah and it wasn't I mean it may sound
creepy for me to talk about it but it
was not I mean I I didn't I didn't
really act on these things you know I
it wasn't like I'm like okay well I'm
gonna like stalk this girl I said what
do you mean by fixate just meaning that
I would just spend a lot of time
thinking about these particular girls or
you know I remember you know the girl
that I thought about the most in those
first few years in North Carolina was
definitely Halle womble uh-huh you know
she was a family friend she was older
than me she was Huey years old two years
older she was cute and I just that's all
it took I mean oh she was cute and or as
we would have said she was fine but
that's what we said we said girls were
fine well not in first grade probably
but bond I mean by middle school we
would say I said it and it made me
second third grade I had an older
brother okay you didn't invent the term
I just you know no no I'm just saying
that's that's what we said we didn't use
the term cute they use that today and we
didn't use the term hot that was
something that sounded like
inappropriate we never said a girl was
hot we said a girl was fine
it's but fine yeah so Halle was fine and
you would just you would just find
yourself just daydreaming about her oh
is that what you mean daydreaming and I
dreaming I mean yeah just just thinking
about like how could I knew that there
was such a thing as the institution of a
relationship a girl friend her boyfriend
I didn't actually think you know at that
age that it was something that was a
realistic thing but I do remember as
early as second and third grade having
dreams you know in your kid you can you
have lucid dreams all the time right I'd
I flew and my dreams all the time
regularly had lucid dreams where I would
realize I was dreaming and then control
the dream in almost every single dream
that I had had where I was that lucid
dreaming the first thing I do was fly
and then when I got up in the air I
would be like mmm well I'm gonna fly to
Holly's house and I would I never knew
what I was gonna do when I got there but
I would always get to her doorstep and I
would her mom would answer the door and
I would say is Holly home and she would
be like right you can't come in
anyway the mom always stopped it so
appropriately yeah why is this flying
first grader at my doorstep but I gotta
say that it did start at that point I
never taught her in real life
- Holly yeah yeah yeah all the time and
meaning later in life when she was in
high school when we were both in high
school
hmm I think I got very flirtatious with
her and would say ridiculous things to
her really oh yeah like even we would go
on like these mission trips with church
and stuff yeah you gotta like Trinidad
in other places in the day we she would
go oh I remember that and I would just I
would just say things to her like you
know you're gonna we're gonna be
together I mean I talked just explicitly
tour not explicitly I talked directly
not explicitly that's the wrong wrong
word I didn't talk dirty I did not talk
dirty to her I said things like you know
we're gonna be together you know I know
I'm two years younger than you and it
never it never worked
ages nothing but a number baby you ever
try that one I said some ridiculous
things Wow I do remember saying
ridiculous that's great it was never
successful and then eventually you know
eventually she went off to college or
whatever and I mean it wasn't like I was
obsessed with her the entire my entire
childhood I continue to try later on but
yeah it was her Lisa Lisa Johnson
Johnson she was tall I was obsessed with
her she was older - did she was one year
older and I don't know I so to get to
the real question which is why it's I
want to flip it back on you for this
because I don't know why because this
just seemed like I could not avoid it I
just I just thought about girls all the
time
and and I want to know here's a question
for you what were you thinking about in
adolescence I think I thought about
girls a normal amount like 25% of the
time girls 25% of the time GI Joes 25%
of the time what I'm gonna eat and 25%
of the time school you know friends
everything else catch all kind of a
thing but for you it just seemed like a
unnaturally large piece of your pie so
I'm not saying you know what I didn't
think about girls but I was um
I did I certainly didn't talk to anybody
about it I didn't talk to anybody about
it I would have talked to you about it
yeah I didn't I mean I didn't talk to
you about it I kept a lot of myself but
there are some kids who's like oh she's
my girlfriend
or he's my boyfriend like younger kids I
see these days kind of have the
boyfriend-girlfriend thing you didn't
have that until you know it was like
official go time middle school when you
could really go with somebody
quote-unquote well and I will say that
it you know it wasn't and so I spent
those first few years and as you did too
I mean thinking about girls okay a
certain percentage of the time maybe
higher for me but there was no action
taken you know I was still just doing
things like playing sports and you know
doing school and those kinds of things
and just nervously interacting with
girls that I liked dreaming about them
but sixth grade rolls around and a
really important thing happened over the
summer between fifth and sixth grade and
that is that Leslie Peebles and amber
Stevens and moved into town now they
weren't sisters they actually moved from
different places but they became best
friends so they were like the two new
girls on the block yeah and both very
cute oh yeah
and kind of could have been sisters at
that age he kind of okay that did they
moved at the same time are they sisters
no well and you got a to put this into
context not that it mattered if they
were sisters I don't know why they would
have been twins probably if we grew up
in such a small place
you know Buies Creek North Carolina
there's you know a thousand people there
you know when the students are Campbell
University are out of town and with
something and they actually both moved
to Lillington the neighboring city town
but they both came to boys Creek
Elementary for reasons I didn't know I
don't know I don't know why they chose
Buies Creek but they did that but but
Leslie became your first girlfriend is
6th grade was that a result of you
pinpointing your obsessive obsession on
her well of course yeah
what happened as soon as they both moved
to town and this is kind of what I was
getting at when a new girl came into
town it was like a big deal because you
had been with the same 25 people since
first grade essentially with the small
turnover you know oh there's a new
person a person leaves it was like a
testosterone lace bidding war of dating
well yeah I've been spoken it was
becoming that and I think it all goes
back to the way that mrs. Lanier
organized the desks you were in Miss
Campbell's class that year yep for some
reason I remember this story we won't
get into your academic deficiencies I
think they were just perceived but by
that by the administration for some
reason you were actually a good student
but for whatever reason you were in miss
Campbell's class and I was a missile in
ears class and miss Lanier made the
decision to organize the desks in two
sets of four like a cloverleaf and you
faced one another and you know I have
told this story in another context
before a GMM or a live show or something
I don't know but so I'll make it quick
but essentially the way it worked as you
said I set right next to Leslie so at a
90 degree angle with her and I remember
it was so I do I've been sitting there
all year with her like this
but summer was coming and it was it was
the spring time and I had on shorts and
she had on shorts flowers were budding
and it just hit me
Hollan was in the air I was like I could
touch her knee with mine I could touch
her leg with my knee you know I was like
here I've been sitting all year on this
possibility and now I can make it happen
her knee is exposed my leg is excuse and
so I was like oh I'm gonna go for it I
don't know I was and I've been thinking
about it whole time because I was like
this girl is good looking and she sits
next to me and so I remember one day I
just said I'm gonna go for Tanner than
use a very tan all the time I started
slumping down in my chair slouchy
slouching and it's kind of sticking my
leg out towards her and I just kind of
started directing it in her direction I
couldn't see cuz it's under the desk you
know I'm like well know what when I hit
it you know it's like I'm drilling for
something you know this is weird and so
I go a couple inches and then a couple
just more like because this girl's leg
you know and I mean at this point I'm
sitting in an awkward
position and I should have been told to
sit up I look like I'm falling asleep my
head is barely sticking up but above the
top of the desk and she's right beside
basically and then eventually I make
contact
I feel skin on skin and everything
changes and then but she immediately
recoils Oh
and looks at me and I'm like okay
mission accomplished I got our attention
oh that's not accomplished coil but then
I kept eye contact and I moved the leg a
little bit further you make I made
contact for a second time my goodness
she recoiled again at this point you're
like horizontal dude yeah and then she
says Oh Rhett you've got some long legs
I was like you're right baby I do you
didn't say anything I would just kind of
just sit I was like hope I don't know
what I said but then I just after she
said that for a third time after that
again I went in and she she still
recoiled she she always backed off so
weird and then eventually I was like I
sat back up and I was like I think I've
sent a message here you know I've
accomplished something I don't know what
it is yeah change seats then the next
thing that I know like in the days
following that I find out that Tate
Maddox likes Leslie it is becomes known
publicly that Tate Maddox likes Leslie
and then well I like Leslie and you as a
matter of fact I touched her leg the
other day with my knee I didn't say that
but that's what I was thinking I've
claimed her essentially and so well
three times she's mine
that's all it took was finding out the
Tate it was interested to know that I
was also in Shenzhen the buzz so I told
amber hmm that I was interested in
Leslie one thing led to another Leslie's
like yeah I do like Rhett and uh and I
will be I will go with him I will be his
girlfriend and so we started a
relationship all because I reached out
and touched someone and take got you off
the dime yeah yeah and take lost I
remember being in the library
it was the library session that day miss
Campbell's class and word trickles into
the library oh yeah
it is going with Leslie that's what we
call it going and my heart just drops
I'm like man I'm just but I'm just
behind I'm in a different class in more
ways than one all of a sudden I'm single
and what am I gonna do I guess I'll just
have to wait for them to break up I mean
you know I don't even I don't remember
what I was thinking but just cut my
inference from what happened was well I
waited over the course of the summer and
then she became my girlfriend the next
the next year seventh grade yeah cuz we
I mean we only went we only went
together for one month and then she
dumped me for because it was summertime
she was like I mean in actually actually
she I thought I initiated the
relationship through amber and then
amber broke up with me for Leslie she
called me and basically said you know is
summertime you know you know you're
you're five miles away
goodness I go to a different pool you go
to a different pool I mean it's so how
can this relationship work over the
summer let's just be real and I was like
um okay whatever my relationship with
Leslie in seventh grade was short-lived
I remember very little about it but how
did it start because that I can't
remember this is my stomach my question
for you was I know how all my
relationships started and that was with
me initiating them in but my my
recollection of how all your
relationships started was that the girl
it would always initiate I would venture
to guess that's how it happened with
Leslie because that's how it happened
with amber months later
amber sat in front of me in history
class and she one day she played the
game I know somebody who likes you and
so I'm guessing girls how does she like
me no does she like me no and I guessed
every girl except amber yeah and then I
[ __ ] against amber and she's like yep
and then we started going together so it
was it was on her initiative that we
went together and that was seventh grade
seventh grade yeah so you'd you
I dated Leslie my first girlfriend in
sixth grade
you dated Leslie your first girlfriend
in seventh grade then you turned around
your relationship with Leslie was short
uneventful then you start the
relationship with Amber yeah an indica
sativa which is your second girlfriend
in seventh grade yeah and then there's
the that's when the party at the
Lillington Community Center with the
Train oh yeah the caboose or in caboose
they're beside it we're sitting in there
and Simba sod Michael Juby and Anna they
were together and they started kissing
each other yeah and then Mike kind of
the community center what else do you
suppose Mike kind of looks at me and
we're sitting right next to him and he
kind of like gives me the nod like
alright now it's your turn
and somebody oh my goodness so then I
turn and give amber the first kiss of my
life well and so how was that it was
amazing force like seven seconds no you
didn't go seven seconds I specifically
remember you're bad with numbers I went
for seven seconds with amber the first
time that was my first kiss I distinctly
remember you saying web for seven
seconds let's clarify okay so mine was
probably less Reena well time seems to
stop especially when it's your first
kiss a via and Wow that was that was
something to remember especially with
Michael G be right there just kind of
timing it that's how we knew that it was
I lost track it I guess he said four
seconds you got to appreciate Michael
Juve you know I mean he's he's he was
always the smartest of all of us he was
always the one that he always had a
girlfriend he always had a girlfriend
he's one step ahead he's a ladies man
and he was the kind of guy that you know
you needed a Michael Juby in that
situation did give me the knob
yeah if Michael had not had given you
the knob who'd he just stared straight
ahead what were you talking about right
now we may not even be here
you know it's possible we wouldn't even
be here Michael do behind giving you the
nod yeah it changed everything I guess
my experience cuz then you but because
then it was like now you have to catch
up you know you have to date amber no
and you have to kiss him yeah on the
night you did not kiss Lesley needed it
out I was scared I got so close I got so
close but Matt McKinney was there it
wasn't Michael G being us he didn't give
me the knot so I didn't know Matt
McKinney was with amber at the time oh I
was next to him and it would lesbi
Lesley Lesley didn't it Matt didn't give
me the nod so I didn't I didn't fall
through but
Michael Juby was there on the night of
my first kiss which incidentally this is
we're not making this up by the way we
had the same first girlfriend and the
same first kiss my first kiss was also
with Amber small town but we were you
know how II would go over to Campbell
University and we would hang out at
Shell's place
yeah and sometime maybe see a movie
right so then a college campus
underneath D rich auditorium which is
still there today there was a little
restaurant that I don't believe is there
anymore it wasn't there you know
recently and we'd hang out you know
we're middle schoolers kind of hanging
out on the college campus and it's kind
of like a dream come true right and
we're sitting in there and in the little
lounge area and I don't know who Michael
was dating at the time I just know that
he he went out and he kind of comes back
and he's like you know I just went out
there and kissed so and so and I'm like
okay and I remember I had on my my blue
Nike sweatshirt which gave me a lot of
confidence it was actually what I took
my school picture in that year so he he
basically gave me the nod he was like
dude I just went outside and kissed my
girlfriend he gave me he took the lead
and then I knew what I was supposed to
do and I walked out of D rich auditorium
I walked right to that fountain
you know the fountain right outside of
the rich auditorium right there in
between the cafeteria and an auditorium
in the dorm rooms and I sat there in my
blue Nike sweatshirt sat down next to
amber and I just went for it and again
seven seconds because some of the could
be the best not the best seven seconds
of my life but definitely a best seven
seconds of that year and and then I just
walked back into the restaurant and just
kind of gave Michael to hit the nod like
you know mission accomplished
I'm the new man did you ever practice
kissing what do you mean with like oh
like on your hand - no I did I practiced
kissing in the shower I kissed my shower
the nozzle that's not a good simulation
that is as unless that was really
salivating for the most messy good no I
would I would kiss the wall of the
shower pretty embarrassing that's all
another great simulation I don't know I
don't know what yeah I can only imagine
what it was like to what it was like to
receive that first kiss from you he
kisses like he's been kissing a shower
it's like I don't know how I was but no
I never practiced you just saw I just
need practice head on my sweatshirt man
I mean you know just oh man there's
plenty of people who I think I've heard
that many people have practiced by
kissing their hand and so I'm I refuse
to feel totally stupid
it's my confession I brought blood
probably a lot lots of people have
practice now but one interesting thing
here's a question for you is that
shortly after I started dating amber you
began dating Anna now this was eighth
grade eighth grade Anna was the smartest
girl in our school okay and every night
and ever that matters and I remember
finding out I mean this girl like really
smart I remember thinking and I first
thought you were my best friend so not
this is nothing against you I just
remember thinking I thought Anna was the
smartest girl in school she's dating
link and I seriously remember thinking
this doesn't make any sense you sense
any level in compatibility I was like
what are they talking about so did you
have like did you have a in depth
philosophical conversations with this
girl I remember there being anxiety
Laden phone calls that's why I Leslie
dumping by the way because I couldn't
carry on a phone call yeah amber was
very talkative it didn't matter if he
talked or not yeah she just got and bye
Anna I think I figured out how to
actually have like at least a
conversation with a girl on a telephone
I think I still remember a phone number
right now matter of fact okay well I'm
not gonna say it because then we have to
go through and beep the phone numbers
we're saying last names isn't that good
enough for you people right it's Paul
it's probably wrong but whatever
I don't recall the specifics of it no
well I do recall one specific thing I
know you did you did we're gonna and
we're gonna talk about this yes we are
you dated her for a while I mean when I
dated amber pretty much my entire eighth
grade year and I recall you dating Anna
most of that yeah but I do
remember you inviting me somewhere
one night now this is something that way
back on
good morning Chia Lincoln we almost
talked about and I remember saying uh
we'll talk about that another time and
then we never went back and talked about
it so I do want to premise this with
this if this was not a good idea we
don't recommend anything that we're
talking about worst of all I'm not proud
of this but yes I did one night where we
were going to you and I we're going to a
see a movie at a Campbell
our parents would drop us off yeah
instead of going to the movie or like
alright let's just let's just walk off
campus walk over to Hannah's house yeah
you really you want to go to my
girlfriend's house and look in her
windows yeah
and of course I'm like well yeah but I
ain't know what a good friend you are
thanks I mean thanks for including me
and I thought it was weird on a lot of
levels but I was there I was along for
the ride now in fairness we were not
right up against a window we were up
behind a woodpile yeah we were we were a
little we were 50 feet from the house
here further back and it wasn't like we
wanted to see anything specifically it
was the just the idea in general of
being sneaky in I don't know it wasn't
about seeing something it was about the
active clan the clandestine act in
itself was just I don't know what it was
about I was just what the most was it
seems like a good idea is what I was
thinking and this guy's letting me do it
with him so and we so we did see my
girlfriend at the time folding clothes
and she and she was also fully clothed
yeah yeah so there's that but it
happened but saying it's over right I do
can no one ever knew until now no but I
do I do
we never discussed one of the right but
one of the things I've noticed as I ask
you these questions is that you don't
really remember what was going through
your mind very much back then is it
because there wasn't a lot going through
it that's why I dated an aurochs so much
was going through her mind for the both
of us so I mean so what would I mean now
you pretty numbness what do you think
you were thinking that it would be fun
I mean it was great it was yeah this is
a clandestine operation I've never told
you thanks for bringing me
but you'll have to bring me welcome
naughty what you would have done that no
I mean I wouldn't have done it you would
have gone to or did you go to any of
your girlfriends well if I went to my
girlfriend's house I would just go into
the house here can I come in I wouldn't
look to the windows that's a stalking
kind of I don't I don't know if it's me
having a bad memory or me just not
thinking through these things too much
so I don't know the answer to that but I
certainly wasn't one to figure out
what's the latest and greatest thing
that's happening in relationships in
middle school and let me see if I can
let me see if I can blaze a trail I was
more just like okay got a girlfriend I
gotta look into that and I will say you
know I'm you none of the what we're
talking about to you know this week is
designed to be prescriptive in any way
it's just this is this is the story this
is the story of what we did but I will
say that I looked you know we've got
kids now right we've got kids who are
going to be going through some of these
same these same things and I think about
the the nature of these expectations
that we brought to these relationships
that we were that we were in and I think
we come from a different generation we
come from a generation where you did not
typically discuss very much with your
parents like I you know right like we
talked to it to our kids about every
little thing they're going through and
we encouraged this open line of
communication and I think that it's just
kind of a generational thing that our
parents were a little bit more hands-off
with us and so as we were entering into
things like a relationship with a girl
at least maybe just was our
personalities in fact that we were boys
I didn't you know I may have told my mom
like a week later that you know yeah
I've got a girlfriend now and she may
have asked me a question I probably just
kind of clammed up but I do think that
you made the announcement
whereas I didn't what were you saying
well I'm just I've
thinking back on it it guess it's
provided some great stories but he was
so ill-advised I mean I this whole thing
to be like I am a fourteen-year-old boy
in a committed
you know exclusive relationship with a
fourteen-year-old girl it was not it was
not healthy it and I'm not saying that
I'm sure there's some of you out there
who are 14 who are listening or whatever
and I'm not saying that you're you know
okay
yeah you know you're you're too young to
experience a life or you're stupid or
anything like that that's not what I'm
saying I'm saying that like it's just
not a taste not that it's not the time
for an exclusive relationship it doesn't
make any sense to have an exclusive
relationship with someone at that point
in your life well and for me I never
talked to my mom I was actually
embarrassed to tell my mom that I had a
girlfriend who I'm going with
amber or I'm going with Anna it's at a
certain point I had to come out but I
don't know for some reason I just felt
embarrassed to talk to my mom about
having a girlfriend at all I remember I
was at when I was going with amber I was
holding her hand on the bleachers at the
baseball game cuz I didn't play baseball
I was the ladies man that day but your
mom was there watching you play baseball
and she saw me holding hands with amber
oh and I remember just being just
flooded with embarrassment really that
your mom saw me holding hands with a
girl it was just it just seemed like oh
you you shouldn't be doing that her oh I
know I know something about you now cuz
I didn't talk to my mom about I didn't
cheat my mom probably discovered through
some other means that probably through
your mom that I had a girlfriend like
that's the extent that I wanted to
discuss it yeah I don't know just
something about it like my school life
in my whole life I wanted to be separate
my god I didn't want my mom to know that
I was growing up or I had no I don't
know psychologically what was happening
but that's what it was
don't you wish you could go back and
talk to yourself yeah and I think that's
what I apply to to to my kids as you
know the things that I don't want them
to be as clueless as I was because I was
so to myself and guarded and I want I
want my kids to be more comfortable
talking about these things so like
saying the word sex is something that is
not like if my kids ever heard that word
because well I talked to him about it at
a younger age versus an old
because it's just it's just a fact of
life and there's a there is an
appropriate way to discuss things with
kids once they start having questions
that then you're not just dumping
everything on him or it seems like a
faux pas when they get to be older or
expecting them to figure it out on their
own
sure let's move to high school well
there was a pivotal moment I recall this
summer vividly now first of all we've
been and I'd like to apologize to Anna
she's not listening but we shouldn't
have been behind her woodpile
she's probably flattered that it
happened and you know always thought it
was her phone and clothes flattered if
that beans creeped out yes you know as
we've established you know we did that
we did our personality profiles recently
and my number one characteristic was
futurist right and part of that
personality profile is someone who
constantly anticipates and visualizes
the future in obsesses about the future
I think oh yeah that's one of the
reasons I was always obsessed with girls
because I would see a certain reality
with with a girl and then I would live
it out and I would it would literally be
living that that future in my mind and I
remember you remember the river yes
right that's kind of where I'm getting
yeah we would go to the Cape Fear River
and swim like every day especially over
the summer I mean that water would be it
would be like a over 100 degrees outside
maybe and that water would just be the
best thing in the world I remember just
like swimming around there and you would
be talking about ok next year we're a
freshman in high school there's a whole
group of girls from all these other
towns that come together at at high
school and it's just like a it's like
we're funneling out of this one little
pond into this bigger Lake of women and
and then you knew their name I knew
their names I don't know how I knew
their names but I was like Stephanie
she's a cheerleader she's gonna be a
freshman she's a cheerleader and Jamie
and Tabitha Michelle Michelle Stephanie
was from Angier
Michelle was from Lillington Ellington
and Melissa was from Andrew it made no
matter that these girls had boyfriends
they were already going with other
people that didn't stop you from Oh No
having initiating these conversations to
get my hopes up oh yeah man I'm gonna
I'm gonna start going with Stephanie and
I'm gonna hold her hand and you know I'm
gonna I don't even it's that the other
yeah and I'll get me a cheerleader too
and she'll be my girlfriend
her name will be Michelle what yeah I
had it all planned to never talk to
these girls
no no just knew their names never even
met him never even met them know what
they look like we knew what they look
like because from when you'd play each
other in basketball they'd be cheerlead
oh no that is true so we become freshman
at Hornet Central High School and Andrew
North Carolina and boy I just remember
thinking about what I was gonna wear
which was absolutely ridiculous what I
did end up wearing you know like that
first couple weeks of school we you know
it was the Nike sweatshirt you still
have it oh no it wouldn't wear a
sweatshirt it was North Carolina in
August so you you were hot all the time
I remember when I wear that I had a
structure shirt that was a short sleeve
polo that had four different quadrants
quadrants that's the word I remember
that yeah I remember ladies I don't know
what you wore you thought they loved it
you were kind of into like the the
soccer thing you were like um Bros and
soccer shoes which I always thought that
was the absolute dorkiest way anyone
could possibly dress I mean I guess I
also thought I'm six-foot what I was six
foot four and a half in my freshman year
in high school I was what you were gonna
wear and what the getting the ladies I
was wearing I had a pair of white shorts
pair of white shorts and a braided belt
that was about a foot too long and you
would you would you would run around and
run it down your one of your legs
remember that yeah and then I had a pair
of docksiders which were those leather
shoes with the leather laces and you
didn't wear any socks with him you had
these tan legs from hanging out at the
pool all summer I was sober so redneck
how did that go for you it worked
incredibly well I remember you know the
cool thing about high school was not
only did you have all all these new
girls in town or in school but you had
break time which you know after first
period of homeroom or whatever there was
the break at nine o'clock you had like a
10 or 15-minute break where everyone
would stand out there in this really
large the common salman's area
and I just remember it took me a couple
of days to figure out that Jamie Brown
and Tabitha Norris were the two most
in-demand girls in the entire school
school they were sophomores sophomore
was this desta sweet spot when you're a
girl in freshman everyone's like oh
they're a little too young
sophomore year all the seniors want to
date the sophomore girls right and at
least that's the way it was back then
and I remember thinking these are the
two girls that everybody wants I see
them talking to each other right now
I'm gonna just start staring in that
direction so this is kind of like the
knee technique with Leslie except from
these days just with the eyes yeah
and at that point I remember Stephanie
Weber lo remember her yep and she was a
friend of both of them
she's the wing woman for the two of them
and somehow I found out that she was
friends with with her and I was like
well I'm gonna talk to I'm gonna talk to
Stephanie I'm gonna get to know
Stephanie I'm gonna get into this
conversation with her I'm gonna I'm
gonna hint that I like Jamie and maybe
something will happen
long story short well well I think what
happened before anything with with Jamie
around the same time was Tabitha I got
word they liked me a lot right I mean
we're talking the top two in the whole
school whoa what is happening and like
now I have to talk to her and it was
like I'm so good at making things
awkward I think it's because I just I
just instinctively was just so awkward
then now I'm just like I just care I
just I can't help myself now I think
making things awkward now is reliving my
puberty years yes are you constantly
stuck in puberty man so she liked me and
I couldn't believe it I did not know how
to conduct a five minute in the comments
conversation with her I just was not
capable of doing it but I was there for
you at the same time in parallel you had
set your sights on Jamie yeah my
question is I did you technically stalk
her no I mean no I didn't stalk her
there was no internet
you know I never called her I just
started talking to Weber Lowe about it
and I would say I like her and then you
know she goes over to her and then
there's they talk a little bit and then
she comes back over to me and she says
she likes you too I'm like okay I just I
thought that's not what happened I
thought she didn't like you I thought
there was a recoil again you had to push
harder and yeah yeah yeah I'm convincing
the story I mean the first time that I
started the conversation there was there
was probably no interest but I'm
convincing that I'm persistent
you had to touch her in the lit man of
like three and I know with your leg here
with my recipe so there was you know
there was a little bit of back and forth
but within the second week of being at
school I mean we're talking two weeks
into high school we were official yeah
we were academia Drive I mean she I
don't have a car and that was your in
because at that point mm-hmm you see
what I was like dude Tabitha likes you
and she's Jamie's best friend this is
like we're like the Power couples now I
mean we got to get in on this and I
don't think you ever used the term power
no I'm just saying I just I saw an
opportunity there you're like well
double date material yeah at least and
and then you can you can explain what
happened on our first date because the
first date I ever had with Jamie was the
first date that you ever had with
Tabitha oh it was yeah yeah it was it
was like let's go do something together
yet none of us can drive so that means
let's go on a double date all crammed
into the backseat of your dad's Dodge
Dynasty while he and your mom drive us
through the done movie theater keep in
mind this is a four passenger car sedan
and there's six of us in there and all
four of us are in the backseat yeah you
know nothing ready six foot four that's
a great way to get to know somebody were
just crammed up against them and I had
no idea what these girls were thinking
and we went by and pick them up
individually at their houses you know
you came you came over to my house she
probably rode your bike to my house and
then we get in the back we go pick up
one of them pick up the other one and
then we go to done and so there's a poem
alone too
it's a pretty long trip from done from
Lillington to done and this is before
they put the four-lane road in so it was
just a two-lane road and so you just you
know you're just on this two-lane road
for a while and you know the
conversation Wendell pretty quickly but
I remember the pivotal moment where I
decided to try to break the awkward
silence by starting a new conversation
so we're driving down the road and you
know I could see that they were breaking
ground ground on the on the four-lane
and so I you know silent silence silence
and then I'm just like sure will be nice
when they make this road four lanes and
then my dad laughing because he totally
recognized the humor in the situation
yeah and what what we were experienced
he was probably getting a kick out of it
in the same way that I'm gonna get a
kick out of things I do get a kick out
of things with my kids imagine how it
smelled in that car with all of that
sweat and anxiety next yeah that was my
only date with Tabitha I'm pretty sure
it didn't that was entirely your fault
because I just don't understand I could
have kept it going I just I felt like
that was horrible but she I just don't
get it man I know she was like such a
prize you know at that time that's not a
sexist no I'm but I like a trophy yeah
but no well I'm speaking I'm assuming
the perspective that I had at a time it
was 1992 I was a freshman in high school
and I was thinking about things in a way
that I wouldn't advise but that was the
reality I was thinking you could go out
with this girl not only is that awesome
because she's good-looking
period that's all we cared about at that
time super shallow super superficial but
also it was like oh and you get to say
that you're going out with this girl and
I never understood we and we didn't talk
about it it's funny we talk about this
kind of stuff more now than we did then
because I was just like I went forward I
kept pursuing Jamie I was like this is
this is a thing now mom you got to take
me over to Jamie's house or I'm gonna go
over to Jamie's house for this and for
that and we we went out for a couple of
months and then the meanwhile Tabitha's
just going she goes out with somebody
else yeah I'll you know
I I lost out man I don't know what to
say
regret but I do remember after going out
with Jamie for a couple of months I was
like you know what I mean I got like you
know one of the best little girls in the
whole school here right the beginning my
freshman year I mean you know the sky's
the limit I'm gonna break up with her
and see you so we will see what else I
can do
oh no I got overconfident and I broke up
with her and I'm sad to say I didn't
date anyone into my junior year after
that you became a free agent me and then
became unemployed it was like a guy who
declares early for the NBA and then he's
like oh I should have done that right
yeah yeah so yeah I mean I have a track
record you know an English class
Selena Bullard asks me to the FLL dance
she had just broken up with her
boyfriend who shrink looked strangely
just like me
sad sad yeah yeah it looked a lot like
you
so she breaks up with that after they've
been together for years and then she
goes with me she asked me to dance I
think as a jab to Thad right I'm gonna
go with a guy who looks just like you
yeah oh and that's no yeah that's why
you're going with Jamie right so so I
break up with Jamie thinking I'm you
know a free agent now so and then you
didn't have a date to the FLL Dan
because we had planned on going together
okay I guess I'm not going to that
fellow I'll dance and so me and my mom
go pick up Selena and then my mom drops
me and Selena off at the FLL dance and
then I don't know how it happened but at
some point Jamie says she wants to dance
with me so I danced with Jamie and then
another song she's like let's dance
again and then all of a sudden it's
three songs in a row four songs in a row
Jamie is dancing with me and then Selena
comes up and she's like I called my dad
he's picking me up and I'm like I was so
stupid
well and so such a jerk I had this and I
heard through the grapevine cuz I wasn't
there in the fifth dance Jamie's like
she's got her head laying on my shoulder
it's just slowed
well I hear the next day piece of ice
the next you know the next Monday people
are like Lincoln Jane you were all over
each other at the FLL dance so you you
go with one girl and then it Nike I did
not kiss her did not kiss her on the
dance floor but my butt my what I heard
through the grapevine and then talk to
you about later was that Jamie starts
dance with you and then by the end of it
yet she's like basically Dancing with
you like he would dance with a boyfriend
boyfriend and girlfriend with dances yes
lady songs like that when your date
leaves yeah and so I was the jerk but I
think in retrospect she was using me to
make her boyfriend that she got back
together with sad jealous that night and
then in Jamie's retro retrospect Jamie
was doing the same thing to you trying
to make you jealous by loving all up on
her his best friend at the FLL damn was
it saying that girls don't realize is
that guys don't care about that
I mean I hear about yeah and I'm like
that's awesome I see you on Monday and
you tell me the story and I'm like well
how was it yeah there was no felt need
for an apology from me right I was happy
for no tension at all so yeah I was a
little weird man she was dancing like
you had her like head on my shoulder it
was you know pretty cool pretty great
of course you didn't do anything about
it nope and that's what I want to get
you okay and I want to translate this a
little bit into to modern times because
mm-hmm my wife did not propose to me
Riley
Wow yeah we're not gonna talk about this
story of how we met men are wise what
that was we were at a different time in
our lives it was a much more mature
process it's not oh yeah not that we
won't ever talk about that but that's
this is about sort of the adolescent
relationships but I do want to make a
parallel observation and that is that
okay
in modern times current rhett and Link
let's say there's like somebody doing
something or like we have to make a
video that involves going up to somebody
and doing something I am much less
likely to initiate in that situation you
are much more likely to initiate in that
situation
but when it came to these things like
this girl I'm gonna make her my
girlfriend I was much more likely to
initiate in that so it's not that you'd
have a relation have a personality that
doesn't take initiative is that in those
situations you just didn't have a plant
you had no plan well yeah if if if there
was an opportunity to entertain a group
of people like in the in the middle
school cafeteria or in video form or
whatever the case may be I'm I'm I'm
very clear on being able to step up to
the plate and do something that's going
to entertain those people but when
there's something personally at stake
like a relationship with a girl it's
this the anxiety level goes way up for
me there when there's personal
implications for that type of thing well
in the thing that frustrated me is that
you know after I I got high on my horse
and then dumped Jamie then I started you
know trying to initiate with other girls
and I remember one year I sophomore year
maybe maybe junior year you know there
was a girl named Julie late remember her
yeah and she was new she was cute
cheerleader I took the initiative and I
went for it and I don't know basically I
you know you never hear anything from
the girl herself you hear it from her
friend FLE they all communicate she's
like buzz off
no she's like Julie likes link oh really
so you don't even remember you don't
even remember I love how you get me
angry about it no I'm just sorry you
just I I never I never had a
relationship with Julie Lake it you I
know that's my whole point that's my
where my frustration lies is that oh and
then the situation with uh with Jana
Jana was it the same thing well you
didn't like Jana but Jana yeah right
yeah software time though same time in
our lives Jana was a freshman
cheerleader she she said she liked me
she broke up with her junior boyfriend
at the time I didn't have a car but my
mom dropped me off at her house and we
rode around on a four we
we like got pizza and we were eating it
on her bed and she like wanted to kiss
me and I clammed up man I couldn't do it
I could not give her a kiss and I was
like well I've been eating pizza what my
breath smells like pizza I've been
riding a four-wheeler what if us smell
like gas like man I don't know I was
just so I just clammed up I just shut
down I couldn't and you know what I
should be thankful you know who onna who
knows where I would be if I had if I had
gone and you know if I had had had gusto
with the lady what and listen I I'm
thankful you know I think that well
that's what was something I want to say
but I just don't know what was going
through your mind because it was it was
not the thing I want to make clear it
was not a conviction that you shouldn't
be doing things you know it wasn't like
wash it and be kissing girls or
something like that it wasn't based in
that that came a little bit later as we
got older and developed some convictions
about that kind of thing but like moving
in for that first kiss is the most
intimidating thing that I can ever
imagine to this day like bungee jumping
or you know skydiving or like like we're
in one of those batsuits where you're
like jumping off the side of a mountain
and then you could you're flying like
the squirrel suit squirrel suit not a
bat suit yeah that's easy compared to
the first kiss like that's how much
anxiety was associated with that from I
don't and I don't know why but I think
it it it served me well it it protected
me from lots of things perhaps and
listen I in at the same at the same time
I don't know why you know I had this
reckless abandon when it came to
starting relationships and I was it was
very often not successful in fact most
of the time wasn't successful there was
a lot of a lot of failures there was
that really bright spot early freshman
year and then there was some low points
but I didn't ever necessarily that
didn't ever all
I translate into other areas too like I
said to this day I do not enjoy like you
know making people feel uncomfortable or
it's like we have to do a prank or we
had go talk I don't like talking to
strangers you know I still I have
anxiety about those things
but when it was talking to a girl and it
was always just like me I mean it I had
anxiety but there was just this
overwhelming like no this is what this
is your mission this what you're gonna
do in retrospect I should have been a
plot I could have been applying that to
other things
hmm you know but the thing they always
intrigues me about you is I'm just like
well what were you thinking about back
in those days because you were you
thinking about your rock tumbler and
stuff like that cuz you always had like
a thing like a you know go to your house
and yeah yeah I was thinking about
basketball and girls I was thinking I
did think a lot about a rock tell this
rock tumbler that was always going like
I found it in the catalog and then I I
circled it and then I obsessed about it
and then like I got up the money and I
bought it and it arrived and then it was
in the laundry room because it made a
lot of constant noise I remember all the
noise it made and you had to wait you
know as an investment involved and then
the rocks come out and they're smooth
and I never made jewelry I just kept the
smooth rocks because that's the line I
didn't want to cross I was a rock
tumbler not a jewelry maker is that the
next step and rocks tumbling you put
Jules on yeah they wanted you to do that
they would give you mounts and all that
type of stuff make rings and necklaces
and stuff only it wasn't pink that was a
rock tumbler it was red and it was red I
wrong but you I mean I gained confidence
to approach women in college that's
that's when things shifted for me it
wasn't really ever at high school I mean
the the last you know my next serious
relationship in high school was with
Missy and that was I said I said that
like Missy like she's an evil person
which she's not but that was like I
guess I was kind of overcoming like a
lack of confidence at that point when
that was like senior year in high school
kind of a thing that really didn't
totally go away until college when after
Missy and I broke up and then I was
meeting other girls college girls and
then it was hey I'm a more of a
functional human being who can have a
conversation or an adult essentially
yeah you're an adult becoming a closer
to it you know but it took me a long
time it's not that you were acting like
an adult that wasn't what I was implying
no I'm and I'm not saying you were I'm
just saying I guess one thing I am
saying is that I feel like that's a
that's a time you know possibly college
is a good time maybe to have a
girlfriend but no one's gonna listen I
mean if you're out there in your middle
school you're in high school and you're
like I'm determined to have a girlfriend
you're probably just gonna do it anyway
and you're gonna be like III think the
more interesting thing is what I want my
kids to listen to this conversation we
had because you know I don't want to you
know I talked to my kids in a certain
way that I don't like to hey kids let's
sit down on the couch so I can tell you
story time about my first kiss and all
these type of things so that's my
question to you is would you want lock
as a ten year old to listen to this
conversation that we just had how do we
tackle that one hmm
well he's probably not going to a they
don't listen to your biscuits no they
don't it's not intended for them so I
guess so right yeah that is correct
right off the bat answer is no I mean if
I'm going to discuss and I had discussed
I mean he's interested in girls we
talked about it I see some similarities
as I see myself and Jesse sees herself
of course because we're both his parents
in in our kids in in in lock who's older
and you know yeah I try to be very I try
to be very calculated in the way that I
talk about things and then we definitely
I mean even
I mean he's 10 years old and he's got
friends who have girlfriends you know
and so there's this even even at that
age there's this pressure it's like Oh
at some point it's gonna be it's gonna
be expected that he have a girlfriend
whatever that means at that age and so
we talk about that and I say you know if
I could go back you know and tell myself
something it would be don't have a you
don't have a some serious exclusive
emotional you know or physical
relationship with someone at that stage
of your life or high school even because
so many things are changing so many
things are so fragile your your chant
your becoming someone so quickly the
other person is becoming something so
quickly that even though it may be very
difficult to have self-control in those
situations that it's it's worth it you
know that and that's that's what I
that's what I tell him yeah and I think
for Lily who is you know is 11 now it's
me having conversations and first of all
just having a conversation is is a big
win just being able to say who do you
have a crush on I know you have a crush
on somebody you can tell me and you know
it's and then she's like well no I don't
and then one one time we had the
conversation was like actually I do
actually I have two crushes or three or
whatever the case was at the time and
you know she and she kind of broke the
seal on having this conversation with me
her dad and saying yeah I have a crush
on so-and-so and it was oh I saw how my
dad reacted and it wasn't he wasn't
scared or it wasn't weird or no one was
embarrassed or it wasn't awkward it's
just hey it's normal we're having a
conversation you having these feelings
is normal and I was talking about it
it's just part of life it's not this
faux pas though we we speak not of these
things because they're weird and you
shouldn't do that
no so that's the first thing but then
encouraging my kids to just to not dive
into something just because people are
the
friends are doing it you know just kind
of pacing themselves hey you don't you
don't know who you are you shouldn't be
connecting yourself with somebody else
who also doesn't know that in the end
again like I said that's it's just
something that's it's it's so hard to
hear that I mean you could have told me
that at that age I would have not cuz
you don't feel that way you don't you
don't feel like you're becoming who you
are you feel like you are who you are
when you're when you're growing up yeah
you know it isn't until you grow up and
you look back and you're like man I was
just flirting so many things out and I
just did not know I just didn't know
about life even when I'd even when I did
know about it I mean and you even
realized that now I'm just like man I
even even at 8:36 you know I'm like man
when I was thirty yeah what was I
thinking you know you did and I think
that's it hopefully that's a good thing
hopefully you always continue thinking
that as time passes but I I want to
close with one story which is not to
undo everything we just said again did
you don't do as we did don't even do as
we said or say just you know don't do do
the right thing when you were dating
amber I mean when you were dating Hannah
and I was dating amber I do remember at
some point being somewhere somebody's
house and there was some kissing going
on there was always a room but there was
some kissing going on making out yeah it
was yeah you could call it extended
kissing sessions and you know you turn
your head to kiss a girl such that you
know I learned that in the shower in the
nozzle doesn't turn with you that's a
problem keep spraying water right
through the wall the wall just stays
there but a girl will usually turn her
head the other way I kiss the bedpost
once - yeah it remains stationary he's
laying kissing a girl with a neck brace
your mom walks in you're kissing a
bedpost that's weird that's
that's why you kiss the shower because
he's not gonna pull the curtain back
right hopefully so I remember kissing
amber and I do the head turn and now
I've got a clear closing my eyes but for
some reason I open my eyes I'm like who
else is kissing in this room you know
and I look over and I see you kissing
Anna and you have done the same thing
you have turned your head and now we are
making eye contact while kissing these
girls and there was a bit of us but
you're not telling anybody about this no
no there at first there was a bit of a I
should avert my you know we shouldn't be
making eye contact this is unnatural we
shouldn't be doing this but then there
was a second thought it was like you
know this is pretty cool there's my best
friend over there you know
he's kissing a girl I'm kissing a girl
we just made eye contact you know I
would give him a head nod or something
but it would only get creepy yeah no it
wasn't a creepy thing I don't it's just
a moment I don't exactly remember this
moment I do but I can't imagine that it
was more about sizing up the competition
almost like okay you know we got to be
tit-for-tat here you know no pun
intended if you are you know if you're
making progress I got it you know I got
to make some progress to kind of a thing
and Zack wes is over there and you know
kissing somebody he's always in the room
kissing somebody it's like a NASCAR race
there could be an announcer lots of
engines revving I don't know any analogy
is dangerous I guess I should just shut
up I've confessed way too much but yeah
I'm not gonna say that I was happy that
I actually your eyes met mine while I
was kissing my girl five you saying it
was it was it was a moment in our
friendship and I appreciated it well
this has ended on an awkward note but we
cannot apologize for it we can plug a
sponsor and that'll make everything okay
this episode is brought to you by
Squarespace
everything you need to create an
exceptional website for a free trial and
10% off go to Squarespace calm and use
our offer code that's our and lra and dl
it's a great way to support ear biscuits
thanks for hanging out with us I think
this was very conversational you may
have felt like you were just kind of
sitting in on a calm
between the two of us and we want to do
this again we're hoping that monthly we
can have this rhett and Link only
episode but we want to incorporate more
of your questions so maybe make it more
of a conversation with you the listener
well and also you know what else do you
want us to talk about you mean you can
let us know a good way to do that is on
SoundCloud where you can leave comments
right there at different places in the
podcast we will read all those the most
important way that you can help feel the
show and give us feedback is through
iTunes leave a review on iTunes we will
read those you can give a feedback there
of course you can always tweet at us
use hashtag ear biscuits and once we
figure out what it is that we're gonna
talk about next time we have thrown
around maybe talking about the creative
process but we want to hear what you
want to talk us to talk about to each
other and then when we figure that out
we will tweet out and ask a question ask
you to ask us questions so then we can
ask them to each other so it's kind of
like you come up with a question you ask
it to yourself and then you ask it to us
on the internet and then we ask it to
each other on ear biscuits that's how
this works
and/or they can record it and make their
own podcast they don't do that and
realize how easy this is we don't want
any competition I'm not gonna listen I'm
just gonna make my own you can do that
if you want to but we will not promote
it or acknowledge it but we do value
your loyalty but we do not value
competition until next week when
there'll be another one of these find us
on the Internet
[Music]
[Music]